ravi de vous retrouver sur public sénat
à suivre cet après-midi en séance
publique le début de l'examen du texte
réformant la sécurité sanitaire du
médicament
ce texte a été élaboré à la suite du
scandale du médiator ce coupe faim
commercialisé par les laboratoires
servier qui aurait entraîné la mort de
500 à 2000 personnes
alors l'objectif de ce texte présenté en
urgence par le ministre de la santé
xavier bertrand est d'instaurer une plus
grande transparence dans les liens
d'intérêts entre les professionnels de
santé et les industries pharmaceutiques
autre volet important de ce texte il
concerne à la surveillance du médicament
après son autorisation de mise sur le
marché
il y a donc une véritable rupture dans
la gouvernance puisque l'afssaps est
transformée en une agence nationale de
sécurité du médicament et des produits
de santé à l'assemblée nationale les
députés socialistes se sont abstenus sur
ce texte
ils attendent de leurs collègues
sénateurs d'améliorer un projet de loi
qui selon eux permet ne permet pas
d'éviter un nouveau scandale du médiator
tout de suite donc direction l'hémicycle
à très bonne séance à tous mes chers
collègues l'ordre du jour appelle la
discussion du projet de loi adopté par
l'assemblée nationale après engagement
de la procédure accélérée relatif au
renforcement de la sécurité sanitaire du
médicament et des produits de santé
nous attendons l'arrivée de monsieur le
ministre
réglo
monsieur
monsieur watrin pour un rappel au
règlement on attend le ministre monsieur
watrin
le ministre étant arrivée monsieur
watrin je vous cède volontiers la parole
bien monsieur le président je sollicite
en effet la parole pour un rappel au
règlement sur le fondement de l'article
36 alinéa 3 de notre règlement monsieur
le ministre le débat que nous allons
avoir sur ce projet de loi est comme
vous le savez important l'émoi suscité
par les doutes entourant la politique de
vaccination de la grippe à la présence
de bisphénol a dans les biberons encore
la sphère du médiateur témoigne de la
volonté de nos concitoyens d'être mieux
informés et de et de bénéficier partout
où cela est possible d'une information
fiable parce que indépendante ce qui
s'applique au secteur sanitaire
s'applique également l'économie ou les
usagers s'organisent compte les
pratiques de banques qui consiste à
minimiser ou taire certains risques
comme au secteur marchand ou les
consommateurs veulent plus de
transparence par exemple sur la fixation
des prix alimentaires dans les grandes
surfaces
cette exigence corollaire légitime au
libre marché peine néanmoins à s'imposer
or il semblerait aujourd'hui que la
privatisation de la partie presse de
l'institut national de la consommation
pourrait conduire son journal 60
millions de consommateurs à chercher
d'autres sources de financement
notamment sur la forme de publicité
celle ci est aujourd'hui exclues de ce
journal qui est un magazine commerciale
sans publicité commerciale ce qui
garantit son indépendance vis-à-vis des
fabricants et des distributeurs
cette situation est d'autant plus
inquiétante qu'elle s'inscrit dans un
contexte d'hostilité à l'égard de la
publication 2008 le cabinet de monsieur
luc chatel avait appelé l'insee pour
protester contre la publication de la
liste des prix qui flambent en 2010 la
gouvernance de lienz et réorganiser les
associations de consommateurs deviennent
minoritaires au sein du conseil
d'administration
c'est d'ailleurs sans doute grâce à
cette nouvelle organisation du conseil
d'administration amenuisant le rôle
historique des associations de
consommateurs que le ca nouvelle mouture
préconise la privatisation du journal au
motif d'une réduction des ventes
le neuf prochains le conseil
d'administration de lienz et devra
trancher monsieur le ministre le
gouvernement ne peut laisser faire il
doit permettre l'émergence d'une
solution durable et pérenne pour
garantir l'indépendance et la qualité de
ce journal véritable aiguilleurs au
service des consommateurs
merci mon cher collègue dans la
discussion générale la parole est à
monsieur xavier bertrand ministre du
travail de l'emploi et de la santé
monsieur le ministre je vous laisse la
parole le seul président madame la
présidente de la commission sur le
rapporteur mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs le projet de loi que j'ai
l'honneur de présenter avec nora berra a
été élaborée vous le savez toutes et
tous à la suite du drame du médiator
pour qu'il y ait clairement dans notre
pays un avant et un après médiator il
refonde le système de sécurité sanitaire
des produits de santé pour concilier à
la fois sécurité des patients et accès
au progrès thérapeutique
ce projet est l'aboutissement
d'importants travaux d'évaluation et de
débats avec tous les acteurs des
produits de santé et notamment dans le
cadre des assises du médicament
je tiens aussi à saluer les
contributions des missions
parlementaires
cette réforme de redonner confiance aux
français dans notre système du
médicament elle est un tout il y à la
fois des dispositions législatives mais
aussi réglementaires sur lesquelles je
reviendrai en détail lors de ces débats
il ya ensuite des questions
d'organisation interne notamment l'agent
de sécurité du médicament
il en va aussi des questions de
gouvernance je veux vous dire aussi
qu'il ya une dimension européenne dont
je souhaite faire part à l'occasion de
ce débat pour bien voir et bien montrer
que c'est une cohérence d'ensemble que
nous devons bel et bien examiner je le
dis parce que tout début lors de la
présentation du texte a été oui mais il
ya notamment la question du budget qui
n'est pas prévue dans la loi évidemment
parce que les questions budgétaires
relèvent soit du plfss soit du plf
voilà pourquoi je m'efforcerai à chaque
fois de vous donner l'ensemble des
éléments
de manière à ce que vous puissiez avoir
la vision la plus juste possible des
changements engagés par ce texte pour
les mesures qu'ils relèveront du domaine
réglementaire j'ai déjà sollicité les
services du ministère afin qu'elle soit
concomitante avec la mise en oeuvre de
ce projet de loi et que vous puissiez
pour celles et ceux qui le désireront
être aussi consulté avant la publication
de ces textes réglementaires les débats
à l'assemblée ont été riches et ils ont
permis de proposer un texte équilibré un
texte juste un texte efficace je sais
que ce n'est pas forcément dans les
habitudes mais j'ai moi même demandé
comme je le demande à la tribune de la
haute assemblée que dans deux à trois
ans maximum
une évaluation de cette nouvelle
législation soit mise en oeuvre
vouloir les modifications c'est bien
s'assurer que tours a été appliquée
conformément à l'esprit et à la lettre
du texte je pense que c'est mieux dans
un domaine qui plus est comme celui ci
votre commission des affaires sociales a
souhaité apporter un certain nombre de
modifications j'aurai l'occasion d'y
revenir lors des débats mais aussi lors
de mon intervention
premier pilier d'autres réformes la
lutte contre les conflits d'intérêt et
la transparence des décisions
cela passe par deux voix l'indépendance
des experts et l'organisation d'une
procédure d' expertise à la fois
transparente et collégial concernant
l'indépendance des experts la lutte
contre les conflits d'intérêts notre
priorité
cela passe à la fois par la
systématisation de la déclaration
d'intérêts et la mise en place de
sanctions adéquates
tous les acteurs du domaine de la santé
je dis bien tous les acteurs sans
exception les experts externes internes
les associations de patients devront
remplir un des pays c'est à dire une
déclaration publique d'intérêts avec un
formulaire unique pour faire simple pour
faire lisible et pour qu'on puisse avoir
aussi l'efficacité du contrôle
je souhaite que ce type de déclaration
soit étendue à toutes celles et ceux qui
exercent des responsabilités dans le
champ de la santé que ce soit au
ministère dans les administrations
centrales mais aussi pour les principaux
responsables dans les administrations
déconcentrées moi même avant
l'application de la loi qui entrera en
vigueur d'ici quelques temps je rempli
une déclaration et j'ai demandé à
l'ensemble des collaborateurs de monts
cabinet de le faire toutes ces
déclarations seront publics et tous les
observateurs journalistes et experts
seront en mesure de les regarder pour
vérifier les situations et j'aimerais
j'aimerais qu'ils le fassent
sitôt la mise en oeuvre et qu'on
n'attende pas un moment donné de
rebondir sur telle ou telle actualité
pour aller le voir si ces publics
j'estime j'ai pas de conseil à donner à
qui que ce soit mais j'aimerais que
comme ces publics tous les observateurs
jamais avare de commentaires puisse
également regarder les choses et dire
des choses il m'apparaît aussi
primordial que chaque institution puisse
assumer ses responsabilités dans la
gestion et dans le contrôle des dpi
votre commission a supprimé la
disposition permettant la création à cet
effet au sein de chaque organisme d'une
cellule de déontologie je le regrette je
le regrette parce que je pense que c'est
au sein de chaque structure que l'on
peut être le mieux à même de définir et
d'identifier les liens d'intérêt en
fonction des compétences sollicitées et
je ne voudrais pas parce que s'est
retirée du texte que l'on se visse dans
ces organismes là dans ces structures là
on a plus à mettre en place et
déontologie à d'autres de le faire je
veux que cette responsabilité soit
pleinement assumée nous aurons
l'occasion d'y revenir
par ailleurs votre commission a supprimé
le recours à une charte de l'expertisé
sanitaire
si nous l'avions mise en place c'est
justement pour encadrer la procédure
experte al quant aux règles de
transparence elles sont pas optionnelle
elles doivent être strictement appliquée
quand un expert présent dans une séance
est concerné par un conflit d'intérêt
les décisions et les avis pris lors de
cette séance doivent être nulles et non
avenues obligations qui sera partie
intégrante des règlements intérieurs des
commissions de façon à ce que les choses
soient totalement clair et dépourvu de
toute ambiguïté
la transparence totale c'est la
condition de la confiance c'est aussi
l'obligation pour l'industrie
pharmaceutique de rendre publique
l'existence des conventions conclues
avec les parties prenantes mais aussi
les avantages en nature ou en espèces
que l'industrie leur procure il s'agit
de la transposition du système américain
du sunshine act
et même si cette portée réglementaire je
souhaite que ce soit au premier euro de
façon à ce qu'il y ait une transparence
totale
votre commission a proposé d'inclure
dans les parties prenantes les
personnels
les personnes pardon intervenant dans la
formation initiale des professionnels de
santé
cela va dans le bon sens en revanche si
je peux me permettre
exclure les étudiants non professionnels
aujourd'hui mais qui sont nos
professionnels de demain va à mon sens à
l'encontre notre objectif je sais que
plusieurs amendements propose
d'impliquer les ordres professionnels
pour la publication de ces conventions
il s'agirait dès lors d'étendre les
missions qu'ils ont actuellement au
regard de la loi anti cadeaux
cela me semble être une bonne chose je
rappelle d'ailleurs que le non respect
de ses obligations de déclarations sera
sanctionnée pénalement
j'ai parlé de la lutte contre les
conflits d'intérêts à ne pas confondre
avec la question des liens d'intérêts
des liens d'intérêt parce que nous avons
besoin d'être très clair sur ce sujet
mais je veux en venir aussi à la
transparence des décisions et la
collégialité des travaux des commissions
de l' agence du médicament
le projet de loi oblige à rendre publics
les ordres du jour ainsi que les
comptes-rendus a sorti des détails
explications de vote y compris les
opinions minoritaires
ces informations seront mises à
disposition du public
la composition et le fonctionnement des
commissions de l'agent seront définies
par voie réglementaire sur les principes
suivants ouverture à la
pluridisciplinarité limitation du nombre
de membres et aussi de leur mandat à
l'afssaps
il ya des personnes qui semblent être là
advitam eternam
ce n'est pas une bonne chose dominique
marananchi dont je veux saluer tout
particulièrement l'action efficace et
aussi la parfaite réactivité sur nombre
de dossiers est en train de refonder
l'organisation de lagence celle ci voit
ses moyens renforcés en plfss afin de
pouvoir mieux répondre à ses missions la
transparence des décisions c'est aussi
un système où chaque institution à sa
place avec des rôles et missions
clairement définis pour que le public
s'y retrouve
c'est pourquoi il est indispensable que
l'institution charge de notre police du
médicament soient clairement identifiés
et que son nom je l'assument n'évoque
plus le drame du médiator l'afssaps
deviendra donc l' agence nationale de
sécurité du médicament
ça n'est pas ça le changement de fond
mais je pense que c'est un changement
qui s'impose si l'on veut repartir sur
des bases nouvelles
le projet loi note l'agent un arsenal de
sanctions proportionnées
qui à mon sens on réellement dissuasives
tel qu'un pouvoir de sanctions
administratives financières et je serai
particulièrement attentif à la mise en
oeuvre rapide de ce dispositif
la transparence totale c'est au cycle
financement de l'agent soit désormais
directement assuré par les subventions
de l'état plutôt de l'assurance maladie
qui percevra les taxes et les redevances
de l'industrie pharmaceutique c'est un
changement parce que c'est aussi un
cloisonnement la garantie d'une totale
étanchéité le financement de la rsm sera
augmentée de 40 millions d'euros mesure
incluse dans le projet de loi de
finances pour 2012 est également dans le
plfss en discussion à l'assemblée
nationale
le deuxième pilier de cette loi de cette
réforme c'est pour faire suite à une
phrase qui m'avait profondément marqué
en lisant le rapport de l'igas à la mi
janvier l'igas avait écrit la chose
suivante dans le dossier du médiator le
doute systématiquement avait bénéficié
aux laboratoires servier
c'est pas tout à fait ma conception ni
la vôtre du principe de précaution
le doute doit bénéficier
systématiquement au patient cela vaut
dès l'autorisation de mise sur le marché
du médicament mais aussi tout au long de
sa vie il ne faut pas que le médicament
pour commencer soit juste un peu mieux
que rien il faut aussi qu'il y ait un
réel bénéfice pour le patient
c'est pourquoi j'ai proposé à
l'assemblée nationale un amendement qui
ouvre la possibilité à lagence de
demander que les essais cliniques soient
effectués contre comparateurs
si l'entreprise s'y opposent elle devra
alors le justifier mais disposer délais
même de données comparatives avec le
médicament de référence
c'est aussi je ne vous le cache pas un
combat européen
j'ai des 500 g à plusieurs reprises avec
le commissaire européen john dalli
afin que la réflexion sur la prise en
compte du critère de la valeur ajoutée
thérapeutique pour l'octroi d'une aide
même soit portée soit initiée au niveau
européen à ce stade soyons clairs on n'y
est pas et à ce stade le commissaire
européen et moi même nous ne sommes pas
sur la même longueur d'onde et je ne
lâcherai pas ce combat je ne lâcherai
pas ce combat mais je sais pertinemment
que cela peut prendre du temps pour
convaincre
alors en attendant en attendant je le
dis très clairement nous allons changer
les règles de remboursement en france en
attendant l'évolution européenne
l'assemblée nationale a donc inséré un
article pour que l'inscription au
remboursement soit maintenant soumise à
la réalisation d'essais cliniques versus
des stratégies thérapeutiques de
référence sur ce qu'elle existe en clair
si on ne peut pas empêcher la et même
dans ces cas là on n'empêchera le
remboursement
l'idéal sera bien évidemment un
changement au niveau européen m'ayant un
peu d'expérience à la matière je sais
que cela peut prendre un peu de temps
pour ne pas dire autre chose
donc nous devons changer les règles au
niveau national cela dépend d'où enfin
pour les médicaments présentant un essai
mairie de nouvelles règles doivent être
applicable aucune prise en charge par la
collectivité donc pas de remboursement
sauf sauf s'il ya un avis contraire du
ministre
mais cet avis devra alors être motivé et
les questions sont juste des questions
d'efficacité et pas des questions de
rendement à quand j'étais jeune ministre
je ne vous cache pas on m'avait dit
dérembourser des médicaments vous aurez
des économies avec le recul ces
économies c'est zéro pourquoi tout
simplement parce qu'il ya des reports de
prescription et qu'en définitive le
principe est un principe de bon sens
vaut mieux mettre son argent sur un
médicament efficace que sur un autre
mais là où il ya une difficulté c'est
que c'est un principe de changement
d'habitude parce que un patient est
habitué aux médicaments
un médecin a l'habitude de près
certaines médicaments et à partir du
moment où l'on retire du marché parce
qu'il est inefficace dans ces conditions
là c'est très compliqué à faire
comprendre et à faire accepter
mais l'enjeu n'est pas financier et je
le dis d'ailleurs d'autant plus que vous
pouvez même avoir des reports de
prescription sur des médicaments qui
sont même plus cher mais en ce qui me
concerne s'il est efficace
cela ne pose pas de problème mais en
revanche jamais je ne vous dirais un
déremboursement c'est pour faire une
économie
je n'y crois pas principe d'efficacité
et de bon sens par ailleurs nous aurons
la responsabilité d'accompagner les
professionnels de santé et les patients
dans cette évolution de la prise en
charge thérapeutique
par ailleurs la mêmes ne sera plus
élevée dans le marbre avec ce projet de
loi les études complémentaires
d'efficacité de sécurité pourront être
exigée à tout moment dès qu'il y aura
une suspicion de modification du rapport
bénéfice risque
par les autorités sanitaires et en cas
de non réalisation de ces études elle
même pourra être suspendu ou retirés et
le titulaire de la mm pourra faire
l'objet d'une sanction financière de la
part de l' agence par ailleurs c'était
l'occasion d'un grand débat à
l'assemblée le renouvellement illimité
des mêmes a été supprimée de façon à
voir maintenant un renouvellement
quinquennal pour garantir efficacement
la sécurité sanitaire
il faut aussi pouvoir disposer de
l'ensemble des informations relatives à
la sécurité des produits
le projet de loi oblige les exploitants
informé l'agent ce de toute mesure
d'interdiction de restriction ou de
modification du rapport bénéfice risque
d'un médicament commercialisé dans un
pays tiers
l'europe nous suit sur ce point la
commission européenne propose de réviser
la directive pharmacovigilance en ce
sens avec obligation d'information au
niveau européen les prescriptions
on peut aussi la précéder les
prescriptions aurait même bien
qu'indispensable dans certains cas je
pense notamment aux maladies orphelines
doivent rester des situations réellement
exceptionnel elles doivent donc être
encadrées elles doivent donc voir leurs
risques associés maîtrisé c'est ce que
propose le projet de loi un encadrement
par l' agence de l'utilisation aurait
même des médicaments sous la forme de
recommandations temporaire d'utilisation
en clair la prescription aurait même
pour perdre quelques kilos ne doit plus
être possible
les logiciels d'aidé à la prescription
seront là pour aider les professionnels
de santé à distinguer les indications
qui relève de mm et celles qui sont hors
acp et même et tous les professionnels
de santé pourront donc informer leurs
patients à chaque prescription et le
mentionner sur l' ordonnance
même si j'ai conscience que pour d des
médecins de ville en ville ils ont
parfois à prendre en compte des
prescriptions qui ont été faites
initialement à l'hôpital j'en ai bien
conscience en amont de la mm
l'évaluation des médicaments doit être
mieux encadrée pour garantir un accès
équilibrée au traitement c'est bien le
sens du nouveau dispositif d athées eu
les autorisations temporaires
d'utilisation
il faut avant tout veiller à ce que les
patients ne soient pas privés d'un accès
aux thérapeutiques qui leur sont
indispensables
même si elle n'avait pas été
initialement prévu pour cela
parce que nous savons que dans ces cas
là ce serait une perte de chance je ne
veux pas de perte de chance
enfin tout au long de sa vie le
médicament doit être suivie et tous les
effets indésirables doivent être
notifiés chaque patient pouvant même les
notifier lui même et directement et nous
devons veiller à ce que les alertes ne
puisse plus rester lettre morte comme ça
a été le cas pour le médiator le projet
de loi instaure donc un statut
législatif du lanceur d' alerte et
s'agissant de l'évaluation le texte
institue un groupement d'intérêt public
qui permettra de réaliser des études
pharmaco vigilance et de
pharmacoépidémiologie conjointement
entre la rsm la has
li nvs et l'assurance maladie le texte
comporte aussi des dispositions sur les
dispositifs médicaux pour encadrer
notamment leur publicité ce qui n'existe
pas aujourd'hui
troisième axe de cette réforme des
patients mieux informés des
professionnels de santé mieux formés et
mieux informer aussi il faut donc une
information publique indépendante et de
qualité
voilà pourquoi nous allons créer un
portail public du médicament qui
regroupera les informations à la fois de
l' agence de sécurité du médicament de
la haute autorité de santé et de
l'assurance maladie
mais pour être bien informé un
professionnel de santé doit avant tout
avoir été bien formé que ce soit dans
son cursus universitaire mais aussi tout
au long de sa vie de praticiens
l'absence de lien direct entre les
professionnels de santé les industriels
dans le cadre de la formation permettra
à mon sens d'éviter cette suspicion
le taux de la contribution sur le
chiffre d'affaires de l'industrie
pharmaceutique passera donc de 1% à 1 6%
pour un rendement supplémentaire de 150
millions d'euros
keira au financement de l'afm c'est la
formation médicale continue de tous les
médecins qu'ils soient hospitaliers ou
libéraux
je voudrais également revenir sur le
contrôle de la publicité auprès des
professionnels et sur la visite médicale
et là je voudrais m'arrêter un instant
le rapport de l'igas avait dit il faut
supprimer toute visite médicale et
beaucoup ont applaudi j'ai proposé pour
ma part de procéder par étapes et en
disant notamment qu'il faudrait
contrôler le contenu de la formation
le contenu des informations et j'avais
donc indiqué qu'à l'hôpital
il fallait mettre en place une visite
médicale collective et on me dit que je
serais allé trop loin
mais il faut savoir je sais pertinemment
que les visiteurs médicaux ont toujours
appliqué les consignes qui leur ont été
données par les firmes mais il faut
savoir si on veut changer les choses
oui ou non et moi je pense qu'il faut
les changer je pense que la visite
médicale telle qu'on l'a connue
il faut la changer complètement donc
aujourd'hui nous avons besoin d'y voir
clair des amendements ont été adoptés à
l'assemblée qui restreignent le champ de
la réforme
je pense pour ma part que l'information
faite aux prescripteurs par le biais de
la publicité des entreprises
pharmaceutiques doit être irréprochable
irréprochable voilà aussi pourquoi
concernant les publications
nous allons passer d'un contrôle a
priori et non plus à posteriori mais
nous devrons veiller également à ce que
on ne soit pas empêché ou dans
l'impossibilité ne faut pas qu'on
rajoute des délais administratifs sont
pareils qui empêcherait non plus la
promotion concernant le pilotage de la
politique du médicament
je sais ce que beaucoup ont pensé
comment se fait-il qu en 33 ans
autant de ministres se soient succédé et
qu'aucun d'entre eux n'ait été informé
de la dangerosité du médiator c'est
parce que je pense qu après le scandale
du sang contaminé
il ya une attitude politique qui a
consisté à se remettre davantage
al'expertise ça n'était pas un phénomène
franco-français sa phénomène américain
c'est un phénomène anglo saxons
notamment dans les pays scandinaves plus
précisément et en fin de compte on a
donné un maximum de place à l' expertise
et résultats des douze avaient camp des
politiques disent je n'étais pas au
courant soit personne ne les croit soit
personne ne trouve ça normal
je pense aujourd'hui qu'il faut ramener
davantage d'informations au niveau du
ministère parce que la responsabilité
publique la responsabilité politique
d'un ministre elle ne se partage pas et
elle ne se délègue pas voilà pourquoi je
souhaite la création d'un comité
stratégique de la politique des produits
de santé et de la sécurité sanitaire
chaque semaine ce comité devra se réunir
en comité opérationnel avec un
représentant du ministre pas du
ministère du ministre et en comité
stratégique tous les trimestres sous la
présidence du ministre lui-même et
seront passées notamment
vu tous les médicaments qui sont sous
surveillance
à charge pour le ministre de voir
comment il compte assumer et exercer
lui-même son regard sur ces sujets là
mais de façon à ce que personne ne
puisse dire avec un médicaments placés
sous surveillance
je n'étais pas au courant vous le voyez
il s'agit d'une réforme d'ampleur et je
sais aussi que cette réforme a fait
couler beaucoup d'encre mais nombreux
sont celles et ceux qui aujourd'hui
reconnaissent qu'il y aura vraiment un
avant et un après médiator
j'ai conscience également avec un peu
d'expérience que voter un texte aussi
ambitieux que celui ci est une chose
mais que nous devons aussi veiller à sa
mise en oeuvre effective et rapide
je vous ai parlé d' évaluation complète
de cette réforme
je serai ouvert dans ce débat de façon à
pouvoir prendre un maximum d'apport des
sénateurs j'aurais vous dire que je vais
fait également à l'assemblée parce que
je pense que sur un sujet comme celui ci
quand on est capable de s'éloigner des
réflexes partisans les français se
disent il ya peut-être davantage
l'occasion de faire confiance il ya
tellement d'occasions tellement de
sujets sur lesquels nous nous affrontons
qu'il est peut-être possible sur
certains points si l'on s'entend que les
français se disent la politique du
médicament
elle n'est pas de droite allait pas de
gauche elle veille avant tout à nous
protéger
je suis sûr que nos débats seront
constructifs et je pense que nous
pourrons aussi faire la preuve que la
santé l affaire de tous et que la
sécurité sanitaire intéresse tous nos
concitoyens je vous remercie
merci monsieur le ministre dans la
discussion générale la parole est à
monsieur bernard cazeau rapporteur de la
commission des affaires sociales mon
cher collègue vous avez la parole
alors monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
depuis la loi de 1998 issues
d'initiatives d'une initiative
sénatoriale qui a créé lab saxe le
projet de loi qu'on examine aujourd'hui
le premier qui traite de la sécurité
sanitaire et des moyens à donner aux
autorités chargées de l'assuré nous
saluons donc un projet de loi qui se
propose de renforcer la sécurité
sanitaire des produits de santé
même si notre satisfaction est tempéré
par l'absence d'un certain nombre de
propositions
fallait-il tout d'abord attendre à la
sphère du médiateur monsieur le ministre
pour rémédier à des défaillances connues
de longue date
celle ci avait été mise en évidence je
vous le rappelle notamment 2006 par le
rapport d'information de notre
commission qui était intitulé
médicaments restaurer la confiance
de même en 2008 qui ont rapport de la
mec de l'assemblée nationale dont le
titre était médicaments prescrire moins
consommer mieux regrettant surtout
ministres le projet de loi paraissent en
retrait par rapport à la réforme
ambitieuse que vous annonciez en janvier
dernier peut-être auriez-vous dû prendre
un peu plus de temps et vous inspiré des
conclusions de la mission commune
d'information du sénat sur le médiator
en particulier pour renforcer le volet
du projet de loi relatif au contrôle des
liens d'intérêt à la transparence
comme je l ai souligné lors de notre
débat en commission ce volet souffre
déjà du fait qu ils recoupent en partie
l'objet et les dispositions d'un autre
texte
le projet de loi relatif à la
déontologie à la prévention des conflits
d'intérêts dans la vie publique du
projet de loi sauver projet de loi qui a
été déposé à la fin juillet sur le
bureau de l'assemblée nationale
cette dichotomie a été voulue m'ont dit
on en raison de la spécificité du
secteur sanitaire
certes un années pas moins gênantes et
risque de se traduire
après l'adoption des deux textes par des
audits ou des contradictions
il est dommage par ailleurs que selon
toute vraisemblance
la future autorité de la déontologie de
la vie publique que propose de créer ce
projet ne soit pas encore en place
lorsque le texte que nous examinons
aujourd'hui entrera en vigueur
nous aurions surtout souhaité dans ce
domaine une démarche plus ambitieuse
nous relevons en particulier que le
projet de loi pour le projet la
nécessité soulignée par pratiquement
tous les rapports suscité par la sphère
du médiator tous les rapports
préconisent de créer un corps d'experts
public indépendant c'est là peut-être la
lacune que le parlement ne peut pas
d'ailleurs puisque nous sommes tenus par
les rigueurs de l'article 40 de la
constitution ne peuvent hélas comblé et
celle que qui fait un petit peu tâche si
vous vous permettez cette expression
dans ce texte que vous avez mis en
oeuvre en ce qui concerne les nouvelles
dispositions relatives aux déclarations
d'un public d'intérêt hormis des rares
cas comme ceux des 1res ou de l'institut
national du cancer ou de telles
démarches de telles déclarations
n'étaient pas encore imposée par la loi
elle n'ajoute pas grand chose aux
dispositions en vigueur et sont même
trop générales pour n'être pas moins
précise que ces dernières quant aux
sunshine act à la française
il est très en retrait sur ministre ou
son modèle américain
même si son champ d'application sur le
plus vaste au point que l'on pourrait
presque parler de cet acte
en ce qui concerne l afssaps le texte
propose d'abord de changer son nom
ce changement nous a paru la première
vue cosmétique mais aussi redondant il
nous semble que les médicaments font
aussi partie des produits de santé plus
intéressantes sont les nouvelles
compétences donné à lagence comme la
possibilité de prononcer des sanctions
administratives financières ou celle
d'exiger un droit d'accès aux
informations nécessaires à sa mission
nous approuvons aussi la possibilité de
demander des essais contre comparateurs
actif même si elle est contrainte par le
droit communautaire comme on nous
l'avait exprimé tout
j'en viens au nouveau moyen de la
politique de pharmacovigilance leurs
portes et leurs limites sont celles de
la directive européenne de décembre 2010
qui a modifié en dernier lieu la
direccte identifie novembre 2001 et qui
institue un code communautaire relatif
aux médicaments à usage humain par
rapport les autres améliorations
apportées par ce texte issu de
l'assemblée nationale je soulignerai en
particulier celles qui tendent un
meilleur contrôle des prescriptions hors
autorisation de mise sur le marché ou
l'avait évoqué mais aussi celles qui
tendent à encadrer les autorisations
temporaires d'utilisation qui doivent
cependant rester poli patients il ne
voie d'accès à l'innovation
thérapeutique ne pas oublier cela on
doit toujours garder la voie d'accès à
l'innovation thérapeutique
nous partageons notre souci de mieux
contrôler la promotion des produits de
santé d'améliorer l'information tant des
professionnels que du public
je citerai à cet égard les dispositions
renforçant le régime juridique de la
publicité des dispositifs médicaux et
des médicaments
je me réjouis évidemment la nouvelle
impulsion donnée à la prescription des
médicaments en dénomination commune
internationale
nous avions d'ailleurs demandé à
plusieurs reprises dans des pdfs des
années passées en faire il arrive tout
comme la fixation d'ailleurs d'un délai
pour la généralisation du visage de
logiciels certifiés dead à la
prescription et à la distanciation qui
était attendue depuis longtemps l'avions
demandé à plusieurs reprises de madame
bachelot votre commission s'est efforcé
de renforcer et de compléter et
d'enrichir le texte issu de l'assemblée
nationale l'obligation de déclaration
publique d'intérêts imposés par
l'article 1 du projet de loi à jeudi une
portée trop générale pour être précise
elle s'impose en effet aux membres des
organes consultatifs placés auprès des
ministres dirigeants et aux membres des
organes collégiaux de tous les
organismes compétents en matière de
sécurité sanitaire ou de produits de
france de santé cela recours des
instances fort différente et des
situations très diverses pour ne citer
que quelques exemples
nous voyons des comités de protection
des personnes lagence biomédecine
l'institut de radioprotection et de
sécurité nucléaire l'actuelle afssaps la
haute autorité etc etc
la commission s'est efforcé de clarifier
la définition des liens d'intérêts qui
doit être déclarée d'étendre
l'obligation de déclaration aux liens
noués au cours des cinq années écoulées
de rédiger le texte de manière à ne pas
paraître en limiter l'application aux
seuls membres d'instances collégiale
s'inspirant des préconisations de la
mission d'information sénatoriale a par
ailleurs prévu que le président de la
haute autorité de santé
le directeur général de l'agencé et le
président de l'institut national du
cancer et le directeur général de
l'inserm ne pourrait avoir aucun lien
d'intérêt pendant les trois années
précédant leur prise de fonction ni
pendant la durée de leur mandat
cela nous paraît conforme à l'exigence
de garantir l'impartialité de ses
institutions
la commission a également précisé et
compléter les compétences actuelles en
les étendant à toutes les personnes
soumises à l'obligation de déclaration
publique d'intérêts de la commission de
déontologie créé par la loi du 2 janvier
93 dite loi sapin nous avons voulu aussi
dans les limites étroites de
l'initiative financière à dossier à
cette commission le régime de
déclaration des liens d'intérêts prévus
par l'article 1er du projet de loi en
particulier menaçante est souhaitable
les déclarations d'intérêts du soin
transmises par les autorités car son
destinataire et qu'elle puisse et les
assister pour leur contrôle ils ont pris
note à cet égard de l'intérêt de la cour
des comptes pour une procédure de
déclaration unique auprès d'un organisme
centralisateur l'intervention de la
commission de déontologie nous paraît
d'autant plus nécessaire que ces
missions seront reprises par l' autorité
de déontologie de la vie publique
c'est pourquoi nous souhaitons également
que puisse dès à présent comme la future
autorité exercer un rôle de conseil en
matière de rédaction des déclarations
publiques d'intérêts et de prévention
des conflits d'intérêts
le même article premier prévoit un
nouveau dispositif substantiellement
modifié par l'assemblée nationale
relatif à la publicité des débats des
instances d'expertisé
notre commission en a adopté une
nouvelle rédaction afin de centrer cette
obligation de publicité sur la rédaction
de procès verbaux diffusé en ligne et
précisant notamment le détail des votes
et des opinions dissidentes
cela n'interdit nullement évidemment la
diffusion d'enregistrements audiovisuels
mais une information écrite sera sans
doute plus accessible plus complète et
plus facile à consulter pour éviter qu
une invocation abusive des secrets
protégés par la loi n'entrave la
publicité des débats la commission des
affaires sociales a donné compétence à
la commission d'accès aux documents
administratifs
la cada pour connaître des questions
relevant de l'application de ces
dispositions
cette compétence sera identique à celle
qu'a déjà la cada en matière
d'application des dispositions relatives
à la publicité des débats des assemblées
locales
enfin l'article premier comporte aussi
les dispositions sur l'expertisé
sanitaire et notamment un article
prévoyant l'approbation par décret d'une
charte de l'expertisé sanitaire les
chartes objet juridique mal identifié
vous inspire une confiance limitée juge
tout à l'heure regretté le ministre mais
nous sommes dans une confiance limitée
dans les chartes ans et celle ci nous
sommes nous semblait pas être
l'instrument idéal pour poser des
définitions qui devrait relever du
législateur comme celle des notions de
liens d'intérêts et de conflits
d'intérêts
en tout état de cause cet article
n'avait aucune portée normative et nous
l'avons donc supprimés comme vous l'avez
d'ailleurs regretté tout à l'heure or en
revanche dans nos inspirante des
conclusions de la commission d' enquête
du sénat sur la grippe h1n1
nous avons proposé nous proposons
d'ouvrir les instants expertise à des
spécialistes de médecine générale et des
experts en sciences humaines car il faut
aussi prévenir les biais là autant de
temps x les liens intellectuels ou
académique des phénomènes de pensée
unique ou de pensée de groupe
l'article
du projet de loi traite notamment du
sunshine act à la française qui ferait
l'objet d'un nouvel article du code de
la santé publique pour que lumière sont
effectivement fait sur les liens
contractuels et financiers entre les
laboratoires les divers acteurs et
partenaires du secteur français qui y
verse qu'énumère sur l arctique
il nous a paru nécessaire d'apporter des
modifications substantielles au
dispositif prévu le même article proposé
de modifier un des articles du
dispositif anti cadeaux pour permettre
aux étudiants se destinant professions
de santé à l'instar de ces
professionnels même de passer des
conventions avec les laboratoires de
bénéficier de prestations dites
d'hospitalité nous a pas paru
souhaitable de légitimer ni d'encourager
de telles pratiques et nous avons
supprimé cet oubli de cette innovation
afin de ne pas donner aux étudiants
l'habitude d'avoir recours à l'industrie
pharmaceutique
nous avons en revanche conservé
l'extension aux étudiants de
l'interdiction de principe de recevoir
quelques avantages que ce soit de
l'industrie pharmaceutique janvion
disposition dite du titre 2 consacré
principalement au devenir de l'actuelle
agence française de sécurité des
produits de santé chargés du contrôle de
la mise sur le marché de la sécurité de
ses produits
l'article 4 changé son nom en agence
nationale de sécurité du médicament
celle ci est plus loin il y avait et des
produits de santé
mais dans le sig il n'y avait pas et des
produits de santé nous étions
inégalement convaincu je crois de la
nécessité de ce changement de nom
j'ai dit dès lors que c'était
cosmétiques pour vous est agréable sur
le mini sont en acceptant le principe de
changer de nom mais la nouvelle
dénomination posé plusieurs difficultés
évoquées plus haut plus haut et nous en
avons choisi une entente qui nous semble
plus conforme à la réalité de lagence et
reste plus proche de son ancienne
appellation l'article 5 prévoit des
règles de publicité des travaux des
instances d'expertisé de lagence et se
propose d'élargir son procès
d'administration aux parlementaires
aux acteurs du système de santé cette
réforme a paru intéressant à notre
commission condition que le conseil
d'administration puis réellement suivre
et orienter les actions menées en
matière de police sanitaire
elle adore modifier le texte en ce sens
et garantit l'indépendance des
associations de patients représentés au
sein des comptes du conseil
d'administration de lagence ainsi qu'une
représentation spécifique des
associations de victimes d'accidents
médicamenteux l'article 5bis inspirée
elle serrait pas l'assemblée nationale
propose de confier à la haute autorité
de santé la mise en place d'un portail
public sur les maladies et leurs
traitements
nous approuvons cette mesure utile nous
avons complété pour que cette
information porte également sur le bon
usage des produits de santé
le titre iii concerne le bon usage du
médicament
il procède notamment gelé déjà dire la
transposition des dispositions de la
directive européenne de décembre 2010
relative à la pharmacovigilance les
articles 6 à 9 ans temps de renforcer
l'information et la capacité de l'
agence en charge du médicament d'assurer
cette pharmacovigilance notamment
demandant des études de sécurité
comparative après l'autorisation de mise
sur le marché
ceci bien sûr attendant l'évolution de
la législation communautaire en matière
dans la m ce que vous avez évoquées et
ceux dont vous devrez certainement au
cours du débat nous parlait plus
abondamment
à cet égard nous jugeons
particulièrement important l'article 9
bis pour nous c'est un article majeur
les qui a été d'ailleurs inséré à
l'intérêt intiative du nom d'une de nos
collègues de l'assemblée nationale
catherine lemorton
cet article permet de contourner
l'obstacle comme vous l'avez exposé
d'ailleurs très bien tout à leur compte
permet de contourner l'obstacle du droit
communautaire
faute de pouvoir imposer décès
comparativement de mm cet article les
impose aux demandes au moment de la
demande de rembourser
des médicaments procédure qu'irène
relève de la seule compétence nationale
dans les fêtes des conséquences cette
mesure seront pratiquement les mêmes que
celles d'une réforme de la procédure mm
notre commission d'ailleurs renforcé la
rigueur juridique de cet article
fondamental les articles 10 à 13 ans
cadre les conditions de prescription
l'article 11 en particulier organise la
prescription en dehors des indications
autorisées dit
or à mm en ouvrant la possibilité à l'
agence en charge du médicament de faire
des recommandations temporaire
d'utilisation
lorsque cela lui sont utiles pour la
santé publique
d'autant que la liberté de prescription
du médecin reste total dès lors qu'il
explique à son patient et raison d'une
prescription aura et mène ce type de
prescription est nécessaire et répandues
comme l'illustré l'exemple de la
prescription de l'aspirine à des
patients atteints d'affections
cardiovasculaires comme dans le premier
acte le premier principe c'est celui
d'une action antalgique la commission à
compléter l'information donnée aux
patients pour qu'ils sachent si le
médicament lui sera ou non remboursés la
situation créée par le projet de loi
étend sur ce point assez complexe les
articles 14 et 16 concerne l'accès aux
médicaments et spécialement les
autorisations temporaires d'utilisation
qui permettent aux patients qui en ont
besoin impérieux d'accéder aux
traitements les plus innovants avant
leur autorisation formelle
nous souhaitons bien sûr préserver cet
accès en revanche il ne faut pas comme
l'a souligné la cour des comptes que
l'atpu soit pour les industriels le
moyen de contourner les procédures de mm
et de fixation des prix par le comité
économique des produits de santé lors
par conséquent tenter de parvenir à un
équilibre en limitant la durée de vie
les athées eu et en précisant les
conditions d'octroi des intérêts
nominatives cela étant nous avons choisi
de n'apporter aucune restriction à la
procédure date est nominative
dérogatoire telle qu'elle a été produit
par l'assemblée nationale qui permet de
répondre à des situations rares
et souvent douloureuse l'article 18
porte sur la publicité relative aux
médicaments
nous avons fait le choix d'une
interdiction de principe des campagnes
de publicité mené sur les vaccins par
les laboratoires et nous sommes en effet
essentiel d'affirmer que la prévention
de relever exclusivement de la puissance
publique
l'article 19 mai en place à titre
expérimental la visite médicale
collective dans les établissements de
santé
je vous la vous je ne suis pas
entièrement convaincu de la pertinence
de cette expérimentation
pour autant si l'on mène une
expérimentation il faut la mener
sérieusement c'est pourquoi nous n'avons
pas souscrit au texte l'assemblée
nationale qui en restreignant largement
la porte et nous proposons donc de
préserver le champ initiale de
l'expérimentation
il vous reviendra monsieur le ministre
d'en fixer les modalités
en tenant compte des réalités de terrain
vous proposons ci donne un rôle pilote à
la haute autorité de santé dans
l'évaluation de cette expérimentation
ce qui ne nous empêchera pas d'envisager
d'autres formes de concertation le
moment venu enfin nous souhaitons
l'élaboration d'un rapport sur
l'évolution de la profession de visiteur
médical que nous demanderons à madame la
présidente de la commission ci concerne
de sela le titre iv rassemblé
dispositions visant à aligner dans la
mesure du possible le régime juridique
applicable aux dispositifs aux
dispositifs médicaux sur celui des
médicaments en particulier en matière de
publicité et de respect de certaines
exigences techniques de sécurité
c'est une bonne chose car les
dispositifs médicaux de plus en plus
utilisés ne font l'objet d'un
encadrement limité en droit national et
je garde en mémoire la réflexion d'une
des personnalités entendu dans le cadre
de la préparation de mon rapport qui me
disait texto le prochain médiator sera
un dispositif médical comme une première
étape nécessaire une meilleure
évaluation des dispositifs médicaux
la commission a donc souhaité
la haute autorité de santé dresse le
bilan des règles existantes en termes de
sécurité des dispositifs médicaux et
portes et propose les réformes qui
paraît très nécessaire sur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
la réforme du système de sécurité
sanitaire vous paraît être une avancée
importante vers la sécurité du
médicaments et des dispositifs médicaux
nous sommes tous animés par le souci de
la rendre la plus complète et la plus
efficace possible
espérons que notre débat d'aujourd'hui y
contribuer et prolonge dans le même
climat de dialogue ouvert les apports de
l'assemblée nationale au projet de loi
qui nous est soumis aujourd'hui pour
nous la réalité de la réforme qui
sortira de ce texte est un premier pas
certes important mais que nous aurons à
compléter dans l'avenir
c'est dans cette attente monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues que la commission des affaires
sociales demande au sénat d'adopter le
projet de loi telle qu'elle l'a modifiée
et complétée par les amendements auquel
elle a donné un avis favorable
braun m
merci monsieur le rapporteur dans la
suite de la discussion générale dont le
temps était fixé par la conférence des
présidents à 2 heures la parole est à
madame anne marie escoffier pour le
groupe r d est ce ma collègue je vous
laisse la parole
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre
madame la présidente de la commission
des affaires sociales monsieur le
rapporteur mes chers collègues
comment ne pas souligner monsieur le
ministre la fièvre et pas seulement la
fébrilité qui a accompagné la conception
puis la naissance de ce projet de loi un
projet de loi l'unanimité et là surtout
nos bancs pour l'attester très
impatiemment attendue après les affaires
qui ont jeté un discrédit et suspicions
sur le médicament à usage humain
pas moins de sept rapports pendant les
six premiers mois de cette année par des
instances à l'autorité reconnue pour
démêler les fils de dispositifs où
s'entrechoquent intérêts des patients
intérêts des professionnels de santé
intérêts commerciaux et industriels avec
leur cortège de contradictions dans un
contexte global de dilution des
responsabilités
comment alors ne pas se féliciter de ce
projet de loi un peu tardif comme l'a
souligné notre excellent rapporteur
bernard cazeau mais un projet de loi qui
malgré les imperfections ou
insuffisances qui ont été soulignés
apporte une véritable amélioration au
système que nous connaissons aujourd'hui
il est à ce titre tout à fait symbolique
que le titre premier traite des liens
d'intérêts et fixe un corpus commun de
règles déontologiques tirant ainsi les
leçons des expériences malheureuses vécu
récemment des dispositions qui
s'inscrivent délibérément dans la
prévention des liens d'intérêts et
viendront protéger contre eux mêmes les
multiples opérateurs sous tutelle des
ministres chargés de la santé et de la
sécurité sociale dans le même esprit
obligation est faite à l'industriel
pharmaceutique de déclarer les
conventions conclues avec les acteurs
des produits de santé et les avantages
en découlant une mesure qui conforte le
rôle et la place du conseil national de
l'ordre des médecins
mais qui mériterait d'être élargie pour
rendre obligatoire la transmission de
toutes les conventions et pas uniquement
celles relevant de l'article l 4113 6 du
code de la santé publique aux ordres
professionnels et ainsi faciliter en
toute transparence
la vérification de ces conventions et la
publication des avis rendu le titre de
gouvernance des produits de santé tire
lui aussi la leçon des liens trop
distendu qui existait entre l'afssaps et
son ministère de tutelle
je veux espérer et je suis confiante que
la nouvelle agence française de sécurité
des produits de santé avec son conseil
d'administration recomposée saura être
cette instance de veille d' expertise de
conseil
non seulement entendu mais écoutez du
ministre de la santé pour qu'elle puisse
pleinement s'investir dans le rôle et la
responsabilité accrue qu'elle détient
désormais le titre 3 relatif aux
médicaments à usage humain est au coeur
des préoccupations de tous les acteurs
patients ou professionnels de santé je
voudrais à très grands traits redire 4
des particularités de la france en
matière de médicaments
la surconsommation général des
médicaments en dépit des campagnes qui
se multiplient pour en freiner lusage
par exemple les antibiotiques
le poids de la visite médicale et des
dépenses promotionnelles de l'industrie
pharmaceutique la pratique très répandue
des prescriptions hors autorisation de
mise sur le marché
elle pourrait aller jusqu'à porter à 20%
leur part rapporté au nombre total des
prescriptions et dernier poids une sous
notification des effets indésirables
liés à un produit de santé sur chacun de
ces points notre rapportera été
particulièrement vigilent
et s'est attaché à avaliser ou à
introduire des dispositions équilibré
protectrice des uns comme des autres
je citerai à titre d'exemple l'article
11 relatif aux conditions d'une
prescription hors autorisation de mise
sur le marché qui garanti sans
l'alourdir les modalités d'information
du patient sur les conditions du
remboursement du médicament
je soulignerai encore les améliorations
apportées au texte
s'agissant des autorisations temporaires
d'utilisation facteurs évident
d'innovation mais nécessitant une
particulière vigilance avant de les
mettre sur le marché la place donnée à
la pharmacovigilance et à l'obligation
faite aux industriels pharmaceutiques
autant qu'aux médecins autant aussi
qu'aux professionnels de santé de
dénoncer tout effets indésirables d'un
médicament d'en informer l'agencé
française sans délai est une mesure de
bonne gestion
tout à fait opportune dès lors qu'elle
est accompagnée de la protection
corrélative des personnes ayant signalé
de bonne foi le dit effets indésirables
si dans son ensemble ce texte a bien
cherché à répondre à des problématiques
dont chacun ici mesure la complexité
il n'en reste pas moins que plusieurs
points mériteraient encore d'être en
profonde dit j'en citerai trois c'est le
cas par exemple de la visite médicale
collectif nous avons été nombreux
certainement à avoir été alerté sur le
projet faisant de l'information
jusqu'ici individuel par démarchage ou
la prospection pour certains produits de
santé une information collective
si je fais abstraction du problème
économique et humain qu'entraînera cette
mesure avec la disparition corrélatives
d'emploi de visiteurs médicaux
je ne peux manquer en revanche de
m'interroger sur l'efficacité d'une
information collective dans des
conditions qui me paraissent pour
connaître comme beaucoup ici le monde
des praticiens hospitaliers etc
ro quelque peu aléatoire avoir donné à
cette disposition un caractère
expérimental pour deux ans au maximum
me paraît une mesure de sagesse deuxième
difficulté me semble-t-il d'application
de cette loi
l'éternel problème budgétaire les moyens
dont doivent disposer les instances de
contrôle des risques en général la santé
ars seront ils à la hauteur des
ambitions qu'elle reprend fort attendre
et dans quel calendrier
autre point que je souhaite signaler
celui de la vigilance sur les
dispositifs médicaux eux même si la
pharmacovigilance et clairement
institutionnaliser le projet de loi me
paraît bien silencieux sur la
matériovigilance et pourtant ne
serait-il pas temps de s'interroger sur
l'utilisation de certains matériels sur
les habilitations à leur accorder après
avoir vérifié par exemple les effets en
matière d'irradiation ou de
développement de tumeurs l'hôpital
purpan de toulouse a connu en la matière
quelques mauvaises expériences que nous
n'avons pas le droit de méconnaître
monsieur le ministre
voici un texte dont vous aurez compris
qu'ils répondent à une attente forte
qu'il y réponde bien en dépit de
quelques insuffisances dont nous sommes
assurés que vous saurez les entendre
c'est pourquoi mais mon collègue gilbert
barbier le dira mieux que moi
les membres de notre groupe conscient
dans les améliorations proposées
si elles sont adoptées voterons ce texte
merci ma chère collègue la parole est à
notre collègue jean louis lorrain
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
le projet de loi qui nous est soumis
entreprend donc une réforme volontariste
et ambitieuse
notre système de sécurité sanitaire et
fait suite aux travaux menés par
l'inspection générale des affaires
sociales mais aussi par les assises du
médicament et différentes missions
parlementaires
alors notre assemblée a d'ailleurs
fortement participé à cet effort de
réflexion et je pense à ceux de la
commission d' enquête présidée par notre
ancien collègue françois autain et notre
collègue en ses collègues marie thérèse
hermange
donc nous appuierons sur les travaux et
des recommandations des assises du
médicament et l'ambition comme le sait
la votons ce ministre est de restaurer
la confiance en renforçant la
transparence alors le système
d'évaluation être contrôle du médicament
actuellement vigueur s'est complexifiée
avec la multiplication des instances
impliquées dans le processus sans
parvenir à garantir une expertise
impartiale et indépendante pour la
sécurité du médicament est la santé des
usagers avoir été largement dominée par
le rôle de l'état la politique du
médicament a été libéré de cette tutelle
en 1993 et cette tendance n'a fait que
se confirmer avec la loi du 1er juillet
98 relative au renforcement de la veille
sanitaire et du contrôle de la sécurité
sanitaire des produits de santé destinés
à l'homme qui a créé aussi cette loi a
créé l'afssaps celle d'où deux mille
quintaux de plus relative à l'assurance
maladie
créant la haute autorité de santé nous
avons constaté que l'absence de centre
politique et administrative de décision
crée un déséquilibre laissant le champ
ouvert à toutes les influences comme l'a
souligné l'inspection générale des
affaires sociales dans ce rapport de
juin 2011 c'est pourquoi en retour à la
responsabilité du politique apparaît
indispensable tout autant que les une
refonte de la gouvernance des agences
après un dramatique scandale du médiator
une gestion contestée de la grippe h1n1
est récemment la publication d'une liste
de 77 médicaments sous surveillance
il s'agit aujourd'hui de rééquilibrer
notre système de sécurité sanitaire pour
en renforcer l'efficacité et
l'indépendance et de rétablir la
confiance des français envers le
dispositif de sécurité du médicament
donc il nous est demandé de renforcer la
pharmacovigilance d'un cadre et des
prescriptions aurait même de contrôle de
la publicité auprès des professionnels
de santé de renforcer l'encadrement des
dispositifs médicaux
le projet de loi que vous proposez
monsieur le ministre a le mérite de ne
pas avoir succombé à la tentation de
l'excès en remodelant profondeur notre
système avec pondération
ce texte pose les bases d'un système qui
offrira deux plus grandes garanties tant
pour les patients que pour les
prescripteurs
il ne se limite pas à réaliser quelques
aménagements du dispositif actuel il
n'en modifie en profondeur et le modifie
avec la détermination d'assurer
l'indépendance et la transparence du
système de sécurité sanitaire de
renforcer le processus de
pharmacovigilance d'assurer meilleure
formation des professionnels de santé
d'améliorer l'information du public et
des acteurs du système de santé
alors avant d'évoquer les apports
essentiels du texte mes collègues
rentrent 11 dans des détails
particuliers je tiens à affirmer que la
réforme de notre système ne doit pas
être ressenti comme une mise en
accusation de l'industrie du médicament
les laboratoires de recherche et les
industries pharmaceutiques réalise au
travail remarquable dont notre pays a le
plus vives besoin pour accompagner
l'innovation et permettent des avancées
médicales indispensables à
l'amélioration des soins
bien sûr certains des changements
apportés par le projet peuvent
préoccuper des professionnels de santé
or sans l'instauration d'un système
efficient précis véritablement renouvelé
nous ne parviendrons pas au but fixé sur
à assurer une plus grande transparence
du disque
steve de sécurité sanitaire permettre
une meilleure identification des
responsabilités et grand maître
l'intérêt des patients au coeur du
système
l'expertisé est au coeur de la nécessité
de transparence nos débats doivent
permettre d'identifier les liens
d'intérêts nécessaire avec les centres
de recherche avec l'université avec la
recherche industrielle le besoin de
clarification des rôles et des missions
dix experts internes et externes doit
entraîner une valorisation aussi des
messier et la gestion des déclarations
d'intérêt doit aboutir en fait à
l'éradication des conflits d'intérêts
aussi nous ne pouvons que publicité ce
projet de loi dans les dispositions
constituent de réelles avancées
sinon on invoquera ici que quelques-unes
particulièrement éloquente
le texte entend lutter contre toute
forme de conflit d'intérêt il prévoit
une transparence totale dans la relation
entre l'industrie et l'ensemble des
acteurs du système de santé
il s'agit notamment d'assurer
l'indépendance des experts et de leurs
décisions
à ce titre la déclaration d'intérêts
obligatoire et systématisée à tous les
acteurs du domaine de la santé
elle devra mentionner les liens
d'intérêts personnels ceux des conjoints
ascendants descendants établi au cours
des cinq dernières années
elle sera rendu public et actualisée
l'exigence de transparence s'appliquera
également à toutes les conventions
conclues entre les entreprises les
professionnels de santé les associations
de professionnels de santé patients
les études et les étudiants en médecine
et en odontologie les établissements de
santé les fondations les organes de
presse spécialisés les sociétés savantes
et les organismes de conseil au delà
d'un certain seuil
l'obligation de publicité s'étendra aux
avantages en nature ou en espèces
consenti passé
reprise le texte modifie par ailleurs le
système d'admission au remboursement
d'un nouveau médicament
désormais il faudra que ce médicament
apporte quelque chose de plus par
rapport au traitement de référence
existant donc une agence restructurer
donc va se substituer à l' agence
française de sécurité de sécurité
sanitaire des produits de santé et entre
parenthèses
j'aimerais comment dire mettre en valeur
aussi la nouvelle direction et la
confiance à laquelle nous leur portons
devant la qualité de ces hommes et de
ces femmes qui devront prendre en charge
nous avions déjà pris en charge cette
nouvelle agence afin que le doute soit
au bénéfice systématique du patient la
nouvelle agence de sécurité du
médicament pourra demander à l'industrie
pharmaceutique de mener des essais
comparatifs pour montrer l'amélioration
du service médical rendu par un
médicament par rapport à un médicament
existant et non plus par rapport à un
placebo
les industriels qui refuserait de faire
des essais contre comparateurs puisque
d'une directive européenne
on pèche d'exiger ce type d'essais
devront le justifier l'autorisation de
mise sur le marché la mêmes ne sera
ainsi délivré et la prise en charge des
traitements par la collectivité ne sera
possible que si les médicaments fonte au
moins aussi bien que d'autres
traitements de référence déjà sur le
marché
si les médicaments présentent un ace et
mairie en service médical rendu
insuffisant
aucune prise en charge par l'actuel
collectivités ne sera envisagée la
nouvelle agence sera organisée avec
l'objectif constant là encore d'en
assurer la transparence et la dépendance
et la composition de son conseil
d'administration sera modifié le projet
de loin fait une plus grande pale place
représentants parlementaires désormais
6es supprime la présence de
représentants
des laboratoires et des entreprises
fabriquant ou commercialisant des
médicaments
son mode de financement sera revue donc
l' agence sera financée donc connaux
mistral a dit par une subvention d'état
qui percevra les taxes et redevances de
l'industrie pharmaceutique
jusqu alors directement versés à lagence
les modalités de l'autorisation de mise
sur le marché de sa réévaluation sont
également réformé afin d'en faciliter la
suspension ou le retrait est de garantir
un meilleur suivi du médicament tout au
long de sa vie cela implique par exemple
la réalisation d'études comparatives
contre un médicament de référence
lorsqu'il existe un effort tout
particulier est fournie afin d'assurer
une information efficace et complète des
patients et l'ensemble des acteurs de la
santé la création d'un site internet sur
les maladies et leurs traitements le
renforcement de la place de la
pharmacovigilance dans la formation des
professionnels de santé la réforme
expérimentale de la visite médicale
collective à l'hôpital
nous y reviendrons ou encore
l'instauration d'un nouveau mode de
pilotage de la politique du médicament
autour d'un comité stratégique sont
toutes dispositions du texte qui
participent à cette volonté de même les
modalités publicité pour les médicaments
les dispositifs médicaux seront mieux
encadrées il s'agit enfin de faire
évoluer la place des patients et des
associations patients dans le sens d'une
plus large implication dans le processus
de notification des effets indésirables
d'un médicament
désormais ils pourront notifié
directement tout effets indésirables
suspectés d'être dus un médicament avec
la création d'un recours en cas de non
traitement de la demande mais par nos
amendements
nous tenterons nous devons dire monsieur
le ministre façon très forte rétablir
les dégâts de la déconstruction du texte
issu de la commission des affaires
sociales du sénat tout en proposant nos
améliorations que nous avons labit
de le faire d'un cadre d'un rapport
fructueux avec le gouvernement ainsi le
système de sécurité sanitaire encore
perfectible pourrait être stabilisé
l'ump est mes collègues de la commission
des affaires sociales ne pourront pas
accepter un texte qui ne vise pas à
refondre le système de sécurité
sanitaire des produits de santé
consignes en sécurité des patients et
accès au progrès thérapeutique
merci mon cher collègue
la parole est à notre collègue philippe
darniche pour la réunion des sénateur
non inscrit
il
monsieur le président pour monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
ce projet de loi est l'aboutissement
tant attendu d'un travail considérable
réalisé notamment à travers les assises
du médicament qui ont permis à tous les
acteurs des produits de santé de
s'exprimer librement et dans l'unique
dont le et dans l'unique objectif de
réussir à concilier progrès
thérapeutique et sécurité des patients
tant attendu car nous avions besoin de
ce texte qui puisse enfin restaurer la
confiance que les patients doivent avoir
envers médecins et aux médicaments qui
leur sont prescrits dans un pays où tous
les classements s'accordent à dire que
nous avons la meilleure médecine du
monde
malheureusement le scandale du vioxx et
du médiateur ont ébranlé cette
conscience la base du texte est bonne et
j'adhère notamment aux trois
propositions principales qui sont faites
monsieur le ministre
tout d'abord la création d'une nouvelle
agence de sécurité du médicament qui va
dans le bon sens il paraît
invraisemblable alors que nous avons mis
en place en france le plus grand nombre
d'organismes de surveillance des
produits de santé d'avoir le sentiment
qu'ils ont parfois travailler sans se
concerter
il était donc temps que pouvoir
politique prenne ses responsabilités et
matin aulas a une situation de
cafouillage qui a trop duré
car la chaîne du médicament ne peut pas
être exonéré de sa responsabilité dans
le scandale du médiator
notamment ce qui concerne la délivrance
de la mm la création de cette nouvelle
agence chargée de surveiller le risque
d'un médicament tout au long de son
cycle de vie
en évaluant des dangers et des bénéfices
en fonction des travaux de recherche
plus récent est une excellente mesure
qui doit remettre de l'ordre dans la
chaîne du médicament et rassurer nos
concitoyens sur les produits quand leur
délivre le texte propose ensuite de
renforcer la lutte contre les conflits
d'intérêts objectif essentiel car il ya
trop de soupçons de collusion dans le
domaine de la santé entre la recherche
et l'argent soupçon malheureusement
parfois fondées et le prix à payer peut
être douloureux sur le médiator ce
soupçon pour les familles de victimes
est insupportable il est donc urgent de
modifier le travail des autorités de
santé de leurs acteurs et la décision
d'introduire plus de transparence
par le biais de déclarations
taillez rendu public sous peine de
sanctions est une avancée fondamentale
à mes yeux nous formons en france des
chercheurs de renommée mondiale qui
depuis des décennies en réaliser des
découvertes ex extraordinaire nous
prenons nous nous protégeons aujourd'hui
notamment grâce à des vaccins et des
antibiotiques hyper sophistiqué de
maladies infectieuses encore mortels il
ya quelques années
nous ne demandons pas la fin des progrès
thérapeutiques ce que nous demandons
c'est un pilote un veilleur attentif aux
bonnes découvertes et au moins bonne
c'est chose faite dans ce texte et je
m'en réjouis cependant vous me
permettrez monsieur mise de poser
quelques questions la première en ce qui
concerne la déclaration des effets
néfastes ou inattendus des médicaments
cette déclaration me semble être devoir
être simplifiées aujourd'hui beaucoup de
professionnels ne font pas de
déclaration tard des formulaires et des
démarches sont trop complexes
prévoyez-vous une amélioration de ce
dispositif ma deuxième question la
mission sur le médiator a montré que les
conseils régionaux de pharmacovigilance
manquait cruellement de moyens humains
et financiers les agences régionales de
santé ont elles les moyens pour y
remédier la troisième question
la formation initiale des médecins en
matière pharmaceutique
on va dire pharmacologiques et jugée
insuffisante
je sais que le dpc doit y remédier
mais pensez vous que ce dispositif soit
suffisant pour les éclairer tout au long
de leur exercice de nouvelles
spécialités à parution de marché pour
autant je pense que la visite médicale
doit être maintenu encore faut-il que la
charte censé régler le problème éthique
soit contrôlée il ne faudrait pas
qu'elles appartiennent aux seuls
laboratoires pharmaceutiques
enfin concernant les mêmes qui doivent
résulter d'une évaluation précise il me
semble qu'il faille des retenir en
fonction des évolutions qu'elle apporte
par rapport aux anciens médicaments de
la même classe thérapeutique
monsieur le ministre je profite de
bonnes interventions pour souligner un
problème que vous connaissez et qui
concerne l'efficacité de certains
médicaments génériques
je pense particulièrement au générique
du niveau tyrode ces deux-là des patines
ayant manifestement un effet
thérapeutique différent du princeps
les analyses pratiquées sur les malades
qui d absorber le démontre depuis
plusieurs années est ce dû à l'exception
est ce dû à des doses modifié mais cela
pose un vrai problème de santé publique
dont vous êtes saisis
je souhaiterais que vous nous éclairer
sur ce point de vue il n'en reste pas
moins que ce problème doit être réglé au
plus vite pour éviter des incidents qui
peuvent être majeures en conclusion
considérant que ce texte est une réelle
avancée dans l'objectif de sécurité
sanitaire que nous devons tous savoir
jeu jean soutiendrait vos compositions
avec la majorité de mes collègues nos
nécessaires merci monsieur darniche la
parole est à monsieur jean marie
vanlerenberghe pour le groupe de l'union
centriste
sur le président sur le ministre mes
chers collègues la réforme du système du
médicament enfin c'était le titre du
rapport de notre mission d'information
sur le médiator
ils étaient éloquents effectivement le
présent projet de loi était attendu
suite au drame du médiateur le sénat a
décidé six ans d'ailleurs après avoir
publié un rapport qui étaient restées
lettre morte de se ressaisir du sujet
afin de mettre au jour les
dysfonctionnements de la chaîne du
médicament en france
cette mission d'information a formulé 65
propositions que notre commission des
affaires sociales a adopté à l'unanimité
ces propositions qu'elle nous
souscrivons pleinement tel était
correctement prises en compte
le texte les prend en compte pas tout
merci
pour celles qu'ils sont prises en compte
mais effectivement un grand nombre de
ces propositions sont de nature
réglementaire elles ne figurent pas dans
ce texte
par ailleurs certaines d'entre elles ne
sont pas neutres en termes de finances
sociales et vous l'avez rappelé monsieur
le ministre c'est donc au sein du projet
de loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale que ces mesures seront traités
ce qui conduit un paradoxe d'ailleurs
auquel nous ne pourrons échapper pour
éviter le morcellement financiers c'est
le choix du morcellement des réformes
qui a été fait une fois ce ménage
effectué que reste-t-il le projet de loi
initial à porte
il faut le souligner des améliorations
substantielles au fonctionnement de la
chaîne du médicament
il retranscrit fidèlement certaines de
nos propositions
il s'agit là donc une très louable prise
en compte par gouvernement du travail de
la mission
dans le même temps nous ne pouvons
qu'approuver les efforts de notre
commission des affaires sociales dont je
salue au passage de travail en
particulier celui de notre rapporteur
bernard cazeau afin d'améliorer encore
la prise en compte des recommandations
de notre de notre mission d'information
notre collègue nathalie goulet se
concentrera sur dans son intervention
sur les question des conflits d'intérêts
mais nous pouvons dire que nous sommes
globalement favorable à vos propositions
même si à mon avis il aurait été
possible d'aller encore un peu plus loin
en excluant complètement les
représentants de l'industrie
pharmaceutique de toutes les commissions
et groupes de travail de l'afssaps et de
la chasse c'était d'ailleurs la
proposition numéro 4 du rapport en ce
qui concerne la gouvernance
le progrès annoncé est indéniable nous
approuvons l'élargissement des
compétences et les pouvoirs de l'afssaps
et finalement ça s'annonce anita
risation mais ce qui nous semble
peut-être
le principal apport de la réforme en
matière de gouvernance est invisible
dans le texte
il s'agit de la création par voie
réglementaire du comité stratégique de
la politique des produits de santé qui
impliquera directement monsieur le
ministre dans le dispositif de sécurité
sanitaire la sphère du médiator a en
effet révélé que le pouvoir politique
pouvait ne pas être directement au
courant des graves dérives alors
abordons maintenant l'un des sujets les
plus déterminants les plus sensibles
celui de l'autorisation de mise sur le
marché
la fameuse à mêmes parce que les
exigences opposable aux demandeurs d'une
à mm relève de la compétence
communautaire
le texte initial se caractérisait par un
profond déséquilibre pour l'octroi de la
mm
une sécurisation insuffisante et après
son octroi de très substantiels progrès
donc sécurisation ex post rien etc santé
ainsi l'article 6 permet à l' agence en
charge de la sécurité du médicament
demandait des études de sécurité et
d'efficacité après la mn et l'article 7
élargi le cas de retrait de m
et l'article 8 fixe les obligations du
titulaire de la mm en matière de
sécurité pour rééquilibrer le texte il a
fallu finasser on peut dire en quelque
sorte contourner le droit communautaire
sans y compte revenir et avec les
articles 6 bis et 9 beast et je crois ce
que le texte est parvenu à faire
l'article 6 bis a inséré par nos
collègues députés rend obligatoire
l'inscription des essais cliniques prêt
à mm sur la base de données nationale de
recherche biomédicale mais le plus
important c'est l'article 9 bis inséré
d'ailleurs aussi par l'assemblée
nationale qui soumet l'inscription du
médicament sur la liste des médicaments
remboursables à la réalisation d'essais
cliniques comparatifs puisque le droit
communautaire et sa logique de grands
marchés sans distorsion nous interdit
d'agir sur les conditions d'octroi de la
haine
le contournement consiste à agir sur les
conditions de remboursabilité du
médicament bravo monsieur le ministre
avec l'espoir bien sûr que vous
arriverez à convaincre le commissaire
européen d'adopter cette attitude
progrès encore en matière de
pharmacovigilance
lors des auditions dans le cadre de la
mission d'information
nous avons été frappés par l' expertise
gaver développer l'assurance maladie en
matière de détection des dangers
potentiels de tel ou tel médicament
cette expertise enfin été prise en
compte puisque le texte fait entrer
l'assurance maladie dans le dispositif
de veille sanitaire pour qu'elle y
prennent toute la part qui lui revient
un mot enfin sur la question de la
visite médicale c'est un sujet très
sensible tant d'un point de vue éthique
économique éthique parce que la visite
médicale mélange information formation
et marketing et économiques parce que
cette activité représente un très grand
nombre d'emplois le rapport
d'information sénatoriale était bien
plus menaçants d'ailleurs pour la visite
médicale que ne l'est le présent texte
il envisageait tout bonnement sa
suppression s'agit sans doute là d'une
solution sage auquel nous arrivons bien
qu'à mon avis pas systématiquement
adaptés
l'expérimentation pourrait en effet
conclure à l'impossibilité de procéder à
des visites collectives
dans tous les cas de figure enfin nous
verrons mais quoi qu'il en soit c'est
toute la question de la formation
continue du médecin qui se trouve là
implicitement posée comment en effet les
médecins se forme-t-il aujourd'hui la
réponse est simple grâce aux labos se
forment par la visite médicale donc par
les labos par le quotidien du médecin
donc les labos par les séminaires
organisés par qui par les labos c'est
bien cela qu'il faut réformer c'est une
question financière qui relève donc du
plfss
tout en continuant de prendre l'argent
de la formation
là où il se trouve c'est à dire dans les
labos il nous faudra bien trouver en
plfss un moyen de soustraire les
praticiens à leur influence marchand
autrement dit couper le cordon ombilical
entre les laboratoires et la formation
continue alors seulement
il sera possible de régler vraiment la
question de la visite médicale d'un côté
on ne supprimera sans doute jamais
totalement la promotion libéral du
médicament d'un autre côté même si les
visiteurs médicaux deviennent des
experts d'état il sera difficile de
conserver les dix sept mille emplois que
cela représente aujourd'hui c'est
pourquoi toute décision ne devrait être
prise qu'en concertation avec la
profession elle-même et avec la has est
sans doute faudra-t-il faire les choses
progressivement
même constat en ce qui concerne la
réforme du prix du médicament sans plfss
qu'il nous faudra la traiter pour
soustraire la formation du prix du
médicament à l'influencé exclusivement
économiques du lobby pharmaceutique
ce constat est partagé par tous
aujourd'hui le poids des industriels au
sein du comité économique des produits
de santé responsable de la fixation des
prix des médicaments est trop important
convient d'en réformer la composition et
le fonctionnement c'est-à-dire
d'augmenter le poids des organismes de
sécurité sociale en son sens en son sein
pardon pour le sanitary zay nous saluons
monsieur le ministre
en conclusion l'ambition de votre texte
et les qualités de votre de vos
propositions
nous attendons maintenant du
gouvernement qu'il prenne aussi ses
responsabilités en plfss
de même nous attendons de l'actuelle
majorité sénatoriale qu'elle prenne
aussi ses responsabilités en allant
jusqu'au bout de sa démarche
constructive que nous saluions il serait
absurde qu'elle ne vote pas le texte
gouvernemental qui s'est ingénié à
améliorer
sous ces réserves les membres du groupe
de l'union centriste et républicaine
soutiendront le présent texte
merci chers collègues la parole est à
madame isabelle pasquet pour le groupe
communiste républicain et citoyen
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
tout le monde l'a dit avant moi ce
projet de loi était très attendu c'est
sans doute la raison pour laquelle la
version que vous avez présenté monsieur
le ministre devant les députés un peu
déçu vous explorez certes des pistes
intéressantes mais sans aller jusqu'au
bout quitte à renoncer à certains des
engagements que vous avez pris lors de
la présentation des deux rapports
successifs remis par l'igas mais je
reviendrai si ce projet de loin était
attendu c'est que ce qu'il est désormais
à lui d'appeler ''l'affaire du médiator
a choqué de concitoyens
tous les ingrédients sont réunis pour
faire de ce cas un exemple de ce que
nous ne souhaitons plus jamais voir se
reproduire un industriel pharmaceutique
aux pratiques salariales douteuses et
des liens étroits avec des délicieux des
décisionnaires politiques des demandes
d'autorisation de mise sur le marché non
conformes aux destinations réel du
médicament des agences sanitaires trop
absente des pressions accrues sur les
donneurs d'alert bref un climat peu
propice à une transparence qui devrait
être la règle puisque elle seule est de
nature à satisfaire les exigences
légitimes de nos concitoyens car c'est
bien de cela dont il s'agit
les agences sanitaires d'un joué un rôle
primordial
elles doivent certes s'assurer que le
médicament n'est pas nocif qui présente
un réel intérêt thérapeutique que son
prix et les conditions de son
remboursement par la sécurité sociale
sont décidés en lien avec ces
performances médical mais elles doivent
aussi s'assurer que les enjeux
économiques l'industriel ne prévalent
pas sur des considérations de santé
publique
sur ce point nous considèrent nos
concitoyens ont l'impression que les
agences ont échoué bien que
symptomatique le cade médiator n'en est
pas nouveau pour autant depuis plusieurs
années des cas similaires sont apparus
je pense en particulier ou bisphénol a
que nous avons personnes partiellement
interdite
ou encore au scandale du vioxx sur
lequel je vais m'attarder un peu en
effet c'est en novembre 1999 que le
vioxx reçoit de la part de l'agencé
européenne des médicaments son
autorisation de mise sur le marché et ce
sans que le vioxx n'ai pu faire la
démonstration à lagence lors des essais
cliniques qu'il apportait un progrès
thérapeutique par rapport au médicament
de la même famille
déjà commercialisé très rapidement lève
déjà food and drug administration met en
évidence les dangers du vioxx notamment
sur la base de l'étude vigor réalisé en
2000 qui porte sur plus de sept mille
malades
la visée de ce produit porté sur une
meilleure tolérance intestinale que le
naproxène vieille anti inflammatoires or
si cette étude conclut effectivement que
le vioxx présente des avantages pour
l'estomac 1 révèle surtout un taux de
facture du myocarde majoré 0,74 pour
centre pour le vioxx contre 0,15 pour le
naproxène et 0,33 pour le celebrex ainsi
le risque cardiaque du vioxx était cinq
fois plus élevé que celui de ses
concurrents
or ni la vidéo ni l'afssaps ni la haine
ne prononceront l'interdiction du vioxx
et c'est le laboratoire merck lui même
qui retirera le vioxx du marché - par
crainte des autorités sanitaires que des
actions de groupe
les fameuses classes actions autorisé
aux états unis si cet exemple est
précieux aussi qu'il contient déjà tous
les prémices du scandale du médiator on
retrouve est déjà là la question des
conflits d'intérêts en effet marcia
angell professeur de médecine sociale
qui a étudié les procès verbaux de la
rda mettra en évidence que quatre des
six membres auraient dû être récusé pour
conflit d'intérêt potentiel tout comme
on retrouve l'intérêt commercial
le vioxx était pour merck ce que l'on
appelle communément un blockbuster qui
rapportait tout de même annuellement au
laboratoire 2 milliards de dollars
comme le soulignait à raison nicole
delépine auteur du livre
la face cachée des médicaments le
scandale du vioxx a révélé qu'il n'était
pas le fruit du hasard mais bien la
conséquence d'un système opaque
d'autorisation de mise sur le marché
dont le souci principal n'est pas la
sécurité du patient mais bien la
création d'un blockbuster au même titre
qu'un film ou un livre
après ce premier scandale nombreux ont
été les acteurs ou les témoins attentifs
à attendre des pouvoirs publics qu'ils
prennent les mesures nécessaires pour
que plus jamais un tel scandale
sanitaire ne puisse avoir lieu
sept ans après le scandale du vioxx puis
l'épisode de la vaccination de la grippe
a h1n1 celui du médiateur éclate avec un
constat dramatique
les gouvernements n'ont tiré aucune
conséquence du passé exposantes deux
filles nos concitoyens aux mêmes risques
on pouvait espérer que ce projet de loi
met un terme à ces situations et
commençait enfin à apporter toutes les
trans par la transparence nécessaire
l'élaboration d'un parcours du
médicament qui ne pourraient plus
souffrir de critiques
hélas si le texte que vous avez déposé
qu'on tenait bien une ébauche de la de
déclaration publique d'intérêts nous ne
pouvions constater que dans le même
temps vous proposiez ni plus ni moins
que d'autoriser les représentants des
laboratoires a siégé au sein même du
conseil d'administration de l'afssaps
cette disposition a été bien
heureusement supprimée par l'assemblée
nationale
pour autant elle témoigne de ce
décrochage entre les aspirations qui
s'exprime et réponses que vous proposez
d'apporter comme par exemple la
disposition qui prévoyait d'étendre aux
étudiants la possibilité de recevoir des
cadeaux de la part de l'industrie
pharmaceutique et de ne déclarer que
ceux excédant un certain seuil
nous nous réjouissons qu'à notre
initiative la commission des affaires
sociales du sénat est supprimé cette
disposition
tout comme elle a adopté notre
amendement prévoyant que désormais
doivent être rendus publics les
avantages de toute nature versés par les
entreprises produisant ou
commercialisant des produits
pharmaceutiques aux parlementaires
nationaux et européens
les membres des cabinets du ministère en
charge de la santé de la sécurité
sociale ainsi que les membres du
gouvernement et d'une manière générale
je trouve
l'article de tel qu'il résulte des
travaux de notre commission constitue un
acquis solides pour notre système
sanitaire disant cela je pense notamment
à la disposition qui prévoit la
publicité des conventions signées entre
les professionnels de santé et
l'industrie que notre groupe et notre
collègue françois autain propose depuis
le rapport sénatorial de dunes 5
restaurer la confiance ou encore
l'établissement d'un registre unique
consultable pour par tous et
gratuitement permettant de prendre
connaissance de telles conventions
l'article 4 de ce projet de loi relatif
aux prérogatives de l' agence sanitaire
sort également renforcée du travail
réalisé par notre commission
naturellement nous sommes favorables à
ce que à tout moment lagence puisse
demander que les essais cliniques
portant sur des médicaments soit
effectuée sous forme d'essai contre
comparé acteur actif
cela permettra d'éviter la situation où
les essais sont réalisés contre des
placebos l'exploitante devant alors
limiter la démonstration de l'efficacité
du produit pour lequel ils demandent une
autorisation de mise sur le marché à sa
supériorité par rapport à un produit
sans effets thérapeutiques
nous saluons le travail réalisé par la
commission des affaires sociales du
sénat qui a également pris en compte les
propositions que nous formulions quant à
la transparence des débats
nous proposerons en séance publique un
amendement concernant la publicité des
conclusions des travaux rendus par les
groupes de travail que nous considérons
être de nature à renforcer le dispositif
prévu dans ce projet de loi
l'article 5 bis qui résultent pour sa
part des travaux de l'assemblée
nationale est également une avancée
notable
elle confie à la chaise en liaison avec
l' agence en charge de la sécurité du
médicament et les caisses d'assurance
maladie
la mission de créer une base de données
de référence sur les maladies et leurs
traitements base qui sera accessible
gratuitement la précision est importante
aux professionnels de santé pour l'aide
à la prescription comme aux patients les
articles 6 et 6 bis vont également dans
le bon sens
puisqu'ils permettent d'améliorer la
pharmacovigilance bien que se heurte aux
dispositions communautaires
il présente le mérite d'exister nous
soutenons et le et le rapporteur et le
gouvernement dès lors que celui-ci
s'engage dans cette voie
raison pour laquelle nous voterons en
faveur de cet article mais l'une de nos
plus grandes satisfactions proviennent
de l'article 9 bis qui subordonne
l'inscription d'un médicament sur la
liste des médicaments remboursés par la
sécurité sociale à la réalisation
d'essais cliniques contre comparé acteur
actif avec cet article
il en est enfin fini du temps aux des
médicaments inefficaces ou moins
efficaces que ceux déjà commercialisés
pouvait obtenir une prise en charge par
la sécurité sociale
désormais c'est un progrès notable seuls
les médicaments présentant un intérêt et
un été réparé thérapeutique pourront
prétendre à une prise en charge par la
solidarité nationale
celle ci retrouve sa vocation initiale
soutenir les patients en assumant une
part de leurs dépenses de soins et n'est
plus considéré comme ce fut trop
longtemps le cas comme une subvention à
l'emploi dans des secteurs qui par
ailleurs génèrent d'importants profits
allègrement répartis entre leurs
actionnaires
de même l'article 13 telle que modifiée
par la commission en prévoyant
d'appliquer aux laboratoires ne
respectant pas leurs obligations non pas
des amendes mais des baisses de prix
s'inscrit dans cette logique de
responsabilisation il d'une meilleure
utilisation des deniers publics ce qui
en période de crise économique ne peut
que tous nous satisfaire l'article 17
qui apporte plus de protection au
lanceur d'alert constitue encore une
avancée particulièrement lorsque l'on
mesure les attaques parfois virulentes
dont les professionnels de santé peuvent
être victimes dans de telles situations
cet article est donc le bienvenu c'est
donc très logiquement que notre groupe
votera pour le projet de loi considérant
que les évolutions qui lui ont été
apportés à l'assemblée comme au sein de
la commission des affaires sociales vont
dans le bon sens c'est-à-dire celui de
plus de transparence et de plus
d'efficacité de notre système sanitaire
pour autant nous considérons que des
améliorations demeure encore possible
certes l'article 1er constitue une
avancée notable
et d'autre part nous nous réjouissons du
fait que la commission ait retenu notre
proposition d'instaurer des mécanismes
n'est mécanisme d'appel à candidatures
pour autant nous considérons que les
déclarations publiques d'intérêts repose
sur la capacité des agences à vérifier
le contenu et la véracité de celle ci
nous craignons qu'à l'heure actuelle
cela apparaisse pour le moins compliquée
notamment en raison de l'insuffisance
des financements qui lui sont dédiés
mais surtout nous sommes persuadés qu'il
est à la fois possible et nécessaire de
permettre l'émergence d'un corps
d'experts internes à l' agence est
indépendante de tout lien avec
l'industrie pharma tu pharmaceutique à
l'image de notre proposition retenue
concernant le directeur de la future
abcès pss mais je suis certaine que sur
ce sujet parce que nous sommes toutes et
tous convaincus de l'importance de doter
l'agencé d'une expertise qui lui soit
propre
nous serons trouver une solution nous
proposons également que soient
sanctionnées les exploitants des
médicaments qui aurait eu connaissance
des faits négatifs sur la santé du
public liés à une utilisation récurrente
dessus dernier dans des cas autres que
ceux ayant conduit à la délivrance de
l'autorisation de mise sur le marché
chacun aura compris qu'il s'agit là
d'une mesure en réaction au cas du
médiator
nous proposons également de renforcer
l'article 9 bis en prévoyant que la
comparaison mais le traitement actif
soit réalisée contre celui présentant le
meilleur service médical cette précision
est importante puisqu'elle servira de
support légal à l'afssaps
l'afssaps pour refuser les études qui
pourrait lui être présentée lorsque ces
dernières sont réalisés avec des
produits déjà commercialisés mais
présentant à smr ou sms en nul ou faible
beaucoup a été fait pour améliorer le
texte proposé par le gouvernement
la commission des affaires sociales a su
pleinement joué son rôle et les débats
que nous allons avoir à l'occasion de
son examen en séance publique nous
permettront encore un peu plus de cars
et clarifier les choses et d'avancer sur
le chemin d
système sanitaire si ce n'est
irréprochable pour le moins plus
transparent plus efficace et au final
plus sûres merci merci ma chère collègue
la parole est à madame aline archimbaud
pour le groupe socialiste europe
écologie les verts
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre
madame la présidente de la commission
des affaires sociales monsieur le
rapporteur
mes chers collègues nous sommes réunis
ici afin d'examiner le projet de loi
relatif au renforcement de la sécurité
sanitaire du médicament et des produits
de santé déposé cet été par vous
monsieur le ministre
dans l'objectif affiché je cite qu'il
n'y ait pas demain de nouveau médiator
l'examen de ce projet de loi et de
location est l'occasion de rappeler
certains fondamentaux de l'éthique
médicale et notamment le fameux précepte
latin au départ que l'on peut traduire
par l'expression d'abord ne pas nuire
ensuite soigner ce principe a notamment
inspiré le texte original du traité
d'hippocrate sur lequel les médecins
prêtait traditionnellement serment en
occident et que leur a longtemps fait
déclaré dans toute la mesure de mes
forces et de mes connaissances je
conseillerais aux malades
le régime de vie capables de les
soulager et j'écarterai 2 tout ce qui
peut leur être contraires ou nuisibles
que la santé ne nuisent pas au patient
quelle évidence a priori et pourtant ce
principe est encore quotidiennement
bafoués au mépris de ses principes
alimentaires élémentaire excusez moi le
phtalate substances classées
cancérigènes mutagènes reprotoxiques de
catégorie 2 par l'union européenne au
point qu'il est interdit depuis quelques
années dans les jouets destinés aux
enfants de moins de trois ans entre pour
plus de 50% dans la composition des
plastiques à usage médical
pour donner un exemple la concentration
de résidus de médicaments et notamment
des antibiotiques antidépresseurs pilule
contraceptive est de plus en plus
importante dans nos rivières et l'eau du
robinet et sont devenus une cause
majeure de pollution de l'eau les
traitements médicaux entraîne de
nombreux effets dits iatrogènes allant
du simple effet secondaire bénin à la
maladie nosocomiale et al la sphère du
médiator en est un exemple
terrifiant qui vient s'ajouter à la
liste noire est bien trop longue des
affaires du distilbène des hormones de
croissance du vioxx de l'isoméride et
d'autres sites et déjà par mes collègues
dans le débat alors bien évidemment il
ne faut pas être de mauvaise foi ses
effets iatrogènes des soins médicaux ne
pourront jamais être totalement
éradiquée et le système français de
pharmacovigilance n'est pas responsable
de chacun d'entre deux ceci dit ne les
considérons sûrement pas comme une
fatalité statistiques et ne nous
résignons pas nous ne pouvons accepter
une situation où les patients sont
parfois mis en danger alors que nous
pouvons éviter une grande partie de ces
drames par une amélioration de la
gouvernance du système de santé de ce
point de vue l'existence de ce projet de
loi par est donc salutaire
bien que nous en déplorions l'arrivée
tardive car en effet il ya quelque chose
de déprimant lorsque nolan lorsque l'on
alerte sans relâche sur les dangers de
telles ou telles pratiques sur les
dérives de tel ou tel système d'en être
réduit à attendre une catastrophe pour
constater enfin un début de changement
concernant le médiator c'est selon des
études commandées par l'afssaps environ
cinq millions de personnes qui ont été
traités avec du benfluorex entre 1976 et
si la succession de défaillances de la
chaîne du médicament avait été évité
c'est plusieurs centaines de vies qui
auraient pu être sauvées puisqu'on
estime et les chiffres sont encore hélas
très provisoire qu'entre 500 et 2000
personnes sont décédées du fait du
médiator monsieur le ministre vous avez
pris l'initiative de déposer ce projet
de loi c'est évidemment il va évidemment
dans le bon sens on peut toutefois
d'abord déploré que ce dépôt soit
intervenue quelques jours avant la
publication des conclusions de la
mission commune d'information sur le
médiator
nous regrettons ce manque de
considération pour le travail de longue
haleine mené par les parlementaires ce
texte paraît tout de même aller dans le
bon sens puisque comme le précise le
rapport sur le médiator trop longtemps
différé une grande réforme du système de
suivi du médicament est désormais
incontournable
le projet de loi dans sa version
initiale était toutefois très loin de
répondre aux besoins de changement que
la sphère du médiator a mis en lumière
il était plus que timoré et d'autres
collègues avant moi l'ont à juste titre
souligné
par exemple il faut pas vouloir nous
faire croire que changer le nom de l'
agence rebaptisée l'afssaps en un autre
nom à nsm suffirait à garantir en quoi
que ce soit la sécurité sanitaire en
resterait dans l' annonce dans l'effet
d'annoncé alors qu'il est clair que
seule une réforme de la gouvernance de
lagence permettra une telle avancée nous
quittons l'hémicycle du sénat merci à
vous d'avoir suivi
l'examen de ce texte concernant la
réforme du système de sécurité du
médicament
prochaine séance demain matin à partir
de 10h30 très belle soirée à tous